sur les brevets je pense que vraiment il
faut faire attention oui il faudra bien
sûr donner des licences et des données
de façon extrêmement il va falloir faire
un peu ce qui s'est passé sur le live
c'est à dire que si vous en rappeler au
tout début des découvertes des
antiviraux on a des parts de donner des
brevets après il ya une pression et qui
a été très favorable et qui
effectivement s'est faite contre
certains industrie pharmaceutique
là je suis d'accord en particulier en
afrique du sud mais elle s'est fait
quand même
après un certain temps je pense
personnellement que là il est trop tôt
et qu'on peut trouver d'autres
mécanismes parce que bien sûr qu'il faut
trouver des mécanismes et ça rejoint ce
que design sénéquier c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il faut un nouvel ordre
international c'est vrai que l'occident
on va parvenir on a été suffisant il ya
un certain nombre de choses et les
cartons étaient totalement rebattues le
grand sujet c'est de ms pour moi s'agit
pas forcément d'aller ré inventer des
choses mais qu'est ce qu'on veut que
soit le mss qu'on veut vouloir est ce
qu'on veut vraiment redonné à le msk
d'oeuvre est et qui d'ailleurs irait
également danseur de ce qu'a dit
christophe prudhomme en termes de
distribution des vaccins des médicaments
il ya vraiment un très grand sujet à
discuter en terme d'ordre international
dans les années qui viennent et je pense
personnellement qu'il faut pas qu'il
aurait inventé l'eau chaude et qu'il
faut et qu'il faut utiliser ce qui
existe
[Musique]